YESTERDAY MEANT.
>> AND THERE WAS A BIG CONCERT
ON CNN LAST NIGHT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
LISTEN, RIGHT NOW, THOUGH, THE
RACE IS ON TO FIND A SUBMERSIBLE
THAT VANISHED WHILE DIVING ON
"THE TITANIC" SHIPWRECK.
FIVE PEOPLE WERE ONBOARD.
THE U.S. AND CANADIAN COAST
GUARDS HAVE LAUNCHED AN ALL-OUT
SEARCH WITH PLANES AND SHIPS AND
BUOYS EQUIPPED WITH SONAR.
IT IS ABOUT 13,000 FEET DEEP IN
THAT AREA.
AS OF YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
OFFICIALS ESTIMATED THE
PASSENGERS MIGHT HAVE HAD
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 70 AND 96
HOURS WORTH OF AIR LEFT IF THE
SUB IS STILL INTACT.
NOW THIS WAS A SIGHTSEEING
EXPEDITION THAT COSTS A QUARTER
MILLION DOLLARS A PERSON.
THE PASSENGERS INCLUDED A
BRITISH BILLIONAIRE EXPLORER, A
PAKISTANI BUSINESSMAN AND HIS
SON.
THERE ARE ALSO REPORTS BY THE
CBC AND CTV NEWS IN CANADA THAT
A FAMOUS FRENCH DIVER AND
"TITANIC" EXPERT WAS ALSO ON THE
SUB.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE LAST
IMAGES OF THE SUBMERSIBLE AS IT
BEGAN ITS DESCENT ON SUNDAY
MORNING.
THE DEEPEST-EVER UNDERWATER
RESCUE WAS LESS THAN 2,000 FEET.
THIS COULD BE UNPRECEDENTED IF
OPERATION -- IF THE COAST GUARD
FINDS THAT SUB.
THAT CONTEXT, THAT COMPARISON,
THE DEEPEST WAS 2,000.
THIS COULD BE AS MUCH AS 13,000.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED OVERNIGHT?
>> Reporter: YOU CAN TELL THAT
SEARCH AND RESCUE CREWS ARE
DEALING WITH A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES.
THE BOSTON COAST GUARD BASICALLY
SAYS THEY'RE SEARCHING IN AN
AREA THAT'S EXTREMELY REMOTE.
THEY'VE REACHED OUT TO EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD OF DEEP SEA
EXPLORATION, AND THEY ALSO
REALIZE AT THIS POINT TIME IS
NOT ON THEIR SIDE.
>> WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
DO TO LOCATE THE SUBMERSIBLE AND
RESCUE THOSE ONBOARD.
>> Reporter: SEARCH AND RESCUE
TEAMS FROM THE UNITED STATES AND
CANADA WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK
TO LOCATE A LOST SUBMERSIBLE
WITH FIVE PEOPLE ONBOARD.
SEARCH PLANES HAVE BEEN SCANNING
THE OCEAN'S SURFACE, SONAR BUOYS
DEPLOYED TO TRY TO DETECT ANY
SOUND FROM THE MISSILE VESSEL.
>> THE LOCATION OF THE SEARCH IS
APPROXIMATELY 900 MILES EAST OF
CAPE COD IN A WATER DEPTH OF
ROUGHLY 13,000 FEET.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO THE
COAST GUARD THE SUBMERSIBLE LOST
COMMUNICATION WITH ITS
MOTHERSHIP, "THE POLAR PRINCE,"
LESS THAN TWO HOURS INTO ITS
DESCENT SUNDAY MORNING AS IT
VENTURED TOWARD THE WRECKAGE OF
"THE TITANIC."
THE COMPANY THAT OPERATES ON
VOYAGES TO "THE TITANIC"
OCEANGATE EXPEDITIONS, RELEASING
THIS STATEMENT.
OUR ENTIRE FOCUS IS ON THE
WELL-BEING OF THE CREW AND EVERY
STEP POSSIBLE IS BEING TAKEN TO
BRING THE FIVE CREW MEMBERS BACK
SAFELY.
ONBOARD BUSINESSMAN HAMISH
HARDING, NO STRANGER TO
ADVENTURE.
>> I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO
THIS.
>> Reporter: RECENTLY HE WAS A
PASSENGER ON BLUE ORIGIN'S JUNE
2022 SPACE FLIGHT.
ON SATURDAY HE POSTED ON HIS
FACEBOOK PAGE, I AM PROUD TO
FINALLY ANNOUNCE THAT I JOINED
OCEANGATE EXPEDITIONS FOR THEIR
RMS "TITANIC" MISSION AS A
MISSION SPECIALIST ON THE SUB
GOING DOWN TO "THE TITANIC."
ONBOARD PAKISTANI BUSINESSMAN
SHAHZADA DAWOOD AND HIS SON
SULAIMAN DAWOOD.
HIS FAMILY ISSUED A STATEMENT
SAYING WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONCERN AND WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST EVERYONE TO PRAY FOR
THEIR SAFETY.
ACCORDING TO OCEANGATE
EXPEDITIONS' WEBSITE THE
21-FOOT, 23,000-POUND
SUBMERSIBLE MADE OF CARBON FIBER
AND TITANIUM HAS UP TO 96 HOURS,
FOUR DAYS, OF OXYGEN FOR FIVE
PEOPLE.
LARRY DALY, A "TITANIC" EXPERT,
HAS BEEN INSIDE THE VESSEL.
>> I WAS IN THE SUB FOR 12
HOURS.
WE HAVE OUR OWN BREATHING SYSTEM
ONBOARD.
IF THAT'S MAINTAINED PROPERLY
LIKE CHANGING YOUR FILTER ON
YOUR CO2 SCRUBBER, YOU CAN STAY
DOWN FOR QUITE A FEW HOURS.
>> Reporter: IN AN INTERVIEW
LAST YEAR OCEANGATE EXPEDITIONS
CEO TOUTING THE SUBMERSIBLE'S
SAFETY.
>> EVERYTHING ELSE CAN FAIL.
YOUR THRUSTERS CAN GO, YOUR
LIGHTS CAN GO.
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO BE SAFE.
>> Reporter: AND ALSO, THERE IS
SOME SORT OF AN EARLY WARNING
DETECTION SYSTEM ONBOARD THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO ALERT THE PILOT IN
CASE SOMETHING GOES WRONG.
ALSO ONBOARD, A SYSTEM IN PLACE
TO HELP THE VESSEL RESURFACE,
AGAIN, IF SOMETHING GOES WRONG.
AGAIN, AT THIS POINT, IT'S JUST
UNCLEAR, VICTOR AND POPPY, WHAT
EXACTLY WENT WRONG WITH THIS
VESSEL.
BACK TO YOU.
>> JASON CARROLL REPORTING FOR
US.
THANK YOU, JASON.
>>> FOR MORE ON THIS LET'S BRING
IN DEEP SEA EXPLORER AND
OCEANOGRAPHER, THE SENIOR
ADVISER AT RMS TITANIC.
LOOK, YOU'VE DONE THIS TYPE OF
WORK FOR THE BETTER PART OF FOUR
DECADES.
HOW LIKELY IS IT THEY WILL FIND
THIS SUBMERSIBLE IN TIME BEFORE
THE OXYGEN RUNS OUT?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY -- HI, POPPY.
CERTAINLY TIME IS AGAINST US AT
THIS POINT, AND THE ONLY THING
WE CAN SAY IT THAT EVERYTHING
THAT CAN BE DONE IS BEING DONE
AND THAT INCLUDES THE COAST
GUARD AT THE SURFACE, LISTENING
BENEATH THE SURFACE, AND
ASSEMBLED SOME OF THE BEST
ROBOTICS PEOPLE WITH ROBOTS AND
SHIPS TO RESPOND RIGHT AWAY IF
THEY DO FIND THAT SUBMARINE.
>> DAVID, WE HAVE THE PICTURES
OF THE SUBMARINE IN THIS PRETTY
BLUE WATER.
IT IS BEAUTIFUL.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING 13,000 FEET
DOWN, GIVE OUR VIEWERS THE
REALITY OF WHAT IT ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE DOWN THERE.
>> IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT WORLD,
VICTOR.
NORMALLY A DIVE YOU BEGIN ON THE
SURFACE IN A LIGHT BLUE, PRETTY
COLOR BLUE THAT WE'RE FAMILIAR
WITH.
IT TAKES TWO AND A HALF HOURS TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM ROUGHLY.
AND YOU START TO DRIFT DOWN
SLOWLY THROUGH THAT WATER
COLUMN.
YOU LEAVE THE BLUE BEHIND.
IT GETS MEDIUM BLUE, DEEP BLUE,
DARK BLUE AND THEN BLACK FOR
ABOUT TWO HOURS.
AND THIS IS A PLACE IT'S BEEN
ETERNALLY COLD AND PRESSURE IS
BUILDING.
SO WHEN YOU LAND, YOU'RE
LANDING, AS I SAID, ALMOST IN A
VERY UNFAMILIAR WORLD WHERE ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
CREATURES LIVE AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT KINDS OF LANDSCAPES.
>> I WAS STRUCK, DAVID, BY THIS
PART OF THE CBS "SUNDAY MORNING"
REPORT LAST YEAR.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO ONE PART
OF THIS.
>> Reporter: THERE'S NO GPS
UNDER WATER, SO THE SURFACE SHIP
IS SUPPOSED TO GUIDE THE SUB TO
THE SHIPWRECK BY SENDING TEXT
MESSAGES.
>> TURN 30 DEGREES RIGHT.
>> PROBABLY 30 DEGREES.
>> Reporter: BUT ON THIS DIVE,
COMMUNICATION SOMEHOW BROKE
DOWN.
THE SUB NEVER FOUND THE WRECK.
>> WE WERE LOST.
WE WERE LOST FOR TWO AND A HALF
HOURS.
>> Reporter: RUSH SAYS HE'LL
OFFER THE PASSENGERS A FREE
DO-OVER NEXT YEAR.
>> IF THEY GOT LOST AND THERE'S
NO GPS, HOW DO YOU FIND THIS
NOW?
>> WELL, THE THING ABOUT THAT,
THAT DOES HAPPEN.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT IT
HAPPENED WITH DAVID POLK, AND
THERE'S BEEN NO COMMUNICATION
WITH THE SUB.
EVEN IF YOU'RE LOST, THERE'S
USUALLY COMMUNICATIONS BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE SUB.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE YOU ARE AND YOU HOPE THE
SURFACE CAN TELL YOU.
SO REALLY IT'S, IN A WAY,
LOOKING ACTIVELY, LISTENING A
BIT BUT LOOKING ACTIVELY WITH
SONARS, A BIT WITH CAMERAS TO
SEE IF THEY CAN LOCATE THE SUB.
AND THE PROBLEM BEGINS WITH THE
LAST KNOWN POSITION, WHERE THE
SUB WAS LAST HEARD.
>> LET'S PUT UP THE GRAPHIC
AGAIN SHOWING JUST HOW DEEP THE
WATER IS AT THE WRECK SITE OF
"THE TITANIC" AND IN COMPARISON
YOU SEE SOME OF THE ICONIC
BUILDINGS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
YOU SEE THE HEIGHT OF, I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE EMPIRE STATE
BUILDING.
DAVID, MY QUESTION TO YOU, GRAND
CANYON AS WELL, WE FIRST MET
YOU, OUR FIRST CONVERSATION WAS
DURING MH-370 WHEN THAT
DISAPPEARED, AND I WAS SURPRISED
BY HOW LITTLE WE KNOW ABOUT HOW
MUCH OF THE OCEAN, BECAUSE "THE
TITANIC" WRECK IS THERE, ARE WE
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PART OF THE
NORTH ATLANTIC THAT WE KNOW THE
DEPTHS, WE KNOW WHAT IS THERE?
>> WE KNOW IT PROBABLY BETTER
THAN MOST PLACES BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN THERE, BUT WE'RE STILL
LEARNING THINGS ABOUT IT, ABOUT
THE CURRENTS THAT SWEEP THROUGH
THERE LIKE UNDER WATER, ALMOST
LIKE A WIND THAT BLOWS BENEATH
THE WATER EXCEPT IT'S WATER,
FROM DIFFERENT QUADRANTS AND
FROM THE NORTH AND THE EAST,
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT THAT.
LEARNING ABOUT THE ANIMALS THAT
LIVE IN THAT SPOT.
WE KNOW IT BETTER BUT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEES AND THERE ARE ALWAYS
SURPRISES.
>> YOU'RE A DEEP SEA EXPLORER SO
YOU HAVE A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE
AND VANTAGE WE DON'T.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE MENTAL TOLL
OF BEING IN THAT SMALL SPACE
WITH THOSE PEOPLE WHO OBVIOUSLY
KNOW NOW THAT SOMETHING WEPT
TERRIBLY WRONG?
>> POPPY, I CAN'T IMAGINE, AND
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY -- A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE, MY CLOSEST
COLLEAGUE AND ONE OF THE BEST AT
THIS, SEARCHING, IS ONBOARD THAT
EXPEDITION.
SOMETHING WE ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
AS EXPLORERS AND SCIENTIST THAT
IS GO TO THE DEEP, AND WE'VE
ALWAYS KNOWN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
COULD HAPPEN AND NOW IT'S
HAPPENED.
WE'RE STILL PRETTY M